welcome everybody welcome to West area
planning my name is Mark Kagura I'm
chairing the meeting this evening
right first housekeeping there are no
fire alarm scheduled that I'm aware of
so if you do hear an alarm please follow
whoever is in the lead out meet in the
carpark opposite or outside the house
the house or the car park offers dance
or the public please note this is a
planning meeting with public
participation or the public meeting
only persons registered to speak will be
allowed to do so we are webcasting this
meeting so if you don't want to be shown
in the World Wide Web then please listen
officer note the appropriate time for
our speakers this evening tips on the
microphone don't speak too closely
otherwise we get a distortion but do
speak clearly and loudly and it will be
fine right the sequence of events for
this evening are as follows I will
introduce the item it's supported by the
case officer who will offer a
description town of proud counselors
will be allowed to speak for up to three
minutes members of the public objecting
will be allowed to speak for up to three
minutes the applicant will be allowed to
speak for a kamesha time either three or
six minutes depending I will give a
hopefully a 30-second warning when your
time's up so you can stop at the
appropriate time thank you
all members will then be allowed to
speak for up to five minutes at all
stages the members of the committee are
allowed to ask questions we then go on
to question the officer on technical
items and then in to debate all this is
detailed to the agenda can I ask please
at your turn your phones either off auto
silent for the duration the meeting
thank you right there is an update sheet
this is for any late-breaking news
members have you had an opportunity to
to see the the sheet and are you happy
to read it I'll take that as a yes thank
you
right Owen asked the officers to
introduce themselves starting from my
right
Caroline mash committee administrator
Ross chambers legal services and
decanter planning manager Tony Horton
senior plumber Richard Bergman planning
officer thank you
right or now start the meeting can I
have the apologies for absence please
apologies receive from counsel Audrey
counsel Charles cants the carriage
councillor Richards and councillor brain
and O'Donnell are substituting thank you
and thank you very much indeed for
substituting this evening thank you
declarations of interest members
Catherine yes number Community Interest
chairman on all three applications on
the county councillor for all of all
three application the first application
double-oh-seven 7 to REM on a near
neighbor but I'm here with an open mind
that's fine thank you very much and the
others met minutes of meeting other any
minutes the same okay thank you right in
that case then I shall start the meeting
our first item on the agenda is
application 1700 772 REM and me unveil
Camden and its Tony is going to be the
presenting officer over to you
Thank You chairman this is reserved
matters application this is the
application siting read here and is part
of a wider site at me on Vale outline
application for various things and this
is one parcel of that of that site
she's phase for a just war annotate
itself cut Station Road to the north
we've got the Camden Road off to the
east
another wider context slide this is
satellites plan and this shows earlier
phases so I can adjust till right
earlier phases the me on bail
development have been developed down in
this corner as you probably know there's
a roundabouts off Camden Road there so
we're looking at the parcel of land HD
right read further north to that another
context your slide this is the master
plan from the beyond rail site and it
shows the site adjectives read here in
context with that wider site so there's
been various there's been various
outlying permissions and reserved
matters approvals for residential use
there's a large commercial activity
takes place in the center yeah there's
permission for leisure village log
cabins camping sites leisure facilities
over on this side of the site and then
we've got some leisure facilities a
ledger center and then some air play
area a skateboard skate park and
what-have-you here and then this part of
the site areas for residential and with
a new primary school in that area as
well and they're just orienting itself
Station Road to the north Camden Road
off to the east there this is the matter
before members this evening the reserve
matters for layout scale appearance and
landscaping and this slide pretty much
encompasses all of that there are 149
dwellings being applied for and as you
can see these are arranged in perimeter
blocks so houses are fronting the
streets or they're fronting areas of
open space probably going to space here
so you prove the blocks which is the the
right kind of design style too for the
layout there's 35 percent affordable
housing as per the requirements of the
of the section 106 and this is spread
throughout the site in a number of areas
and there are little black stars on the
roof
the dwellings which are the Affordable
Unix
the parking is predominantly on plot or
in some areas in front parking areas or
no parking courts so that of course with
the design standards that we've got the
substantial areas of landscaped public
open space particularly to the north via
adjacent station Road that we landscape
buffer area there as area of public open
space there and then there's extensive
landscaping through the sides including
these avenues of trees through the Spry
road and then elsewhere throughout the
site the dwellings are predominately two
stories high with some 2.5 stories in
key locations for example on the on the
corner plots here and overlooking the
open space materials are predominately
red and orange brick with grain plate
tiles for roofs and the appearance and
some properties will be rendered in in
feature locations for example on corner
plots or end vistas I've got a series of
slides which give you some visual
definition of the the appearance so
here's a number of street scenes it
shows a selection of house types there's
a traditional approach to these and the
use of character design features such as
chimneys porches and brick arches over
windows brick lintels and then they've
got a series of perspectives snapshots
from within the estate so you get a feel
for how the estate's laid out how it
appears it's an example of a rendered
property on a corner for example there
some more perspectives so just little
vignettes of how the various roads and
street scenes play out and another one
then I've got serious Birds Eye views
which give you an overall impression of
the sides
if i zoom in on these some of these so
to worry intake itself I've labeled
Station Road that just gives you an idea
the layout and the perimeter blocks and
how that into place with the landscape
open spaces
once again yeah so you're looking across
the site to the North Station Road and
finally I'll show you this aerial view
open space leading in there and in the
buffer zone to the North Station Road
Jevon that's that's it for the
presentation and the recommendation is
to approve the reserved matters thank
you very much our first speaker this
evening is mr. Nigel Millington on
behalf of moderns three minutes thinking
like German and I'm stood a statement
was about to be read in relation to the
highways matters but it's not been read
yet so I'll continue as I planned
and yes I'm a director of Fulgencio
ships and here to talk about how it
matters as they're raising the committee
report and in relation to those matters
that are relevant to the dissemination
of this application no objection has
been received from the higher authority
access was of course approved at the
outline stage a massive detail relating
to the internal site layout have been
discussed and agreed with the County
Council hence the recommendation to
approve with conditions however
counselor bias has raised concerns
regarding the recently improved junction
of Station Road with Camden Road and to
summarize his concerns he suggests that
there have been accidents at that
location that the junction has not been
built in accordance with the approved
plans and that the junction has not been
built to the required standard so just
running through those concerns for May
first in relation to the accidents the
county confirmed to me just yesterday in
fact that no injury accidents and
actually occurred at that location up to
the 15th of June this year which is the
latest date for which data is available
there may have been unreported mine
incidents but there was clearly not an
inherent road safety problem at this
location secondly in relation to the
improvements in question the
installation of a ghost iron right-turn
junction this was approved as part of
the outline application out i consent
rather and it's important to note the
following the junction improvement is
only required prior to the first
occupation of phase D of
a line scheme that phase has not yet
commenced underneath this improvement is
not triggered by less reserved matters
application this matter therefore cannot
hold up the termination of this
application
I put simply it is not a material
planning consideration not with
something this point the junction was
required to be constructed generally in
accordance with the approved drawings
now at the detailed design stage the the
right-turn name has changed from 3
meters wide to put 2.5 meters wide due
to site constraints now in my
professional opinion the constructor
Junction is still generally in
accordance with the approved plans the
committee report notes that the county
of the same opinion and that the
junction has passed all the relevant
rows safety audits and at the section to
terminate agreement has been signed and
it's complete thirdly in relation to
cash flow bars assertion that the
junction is not up to standard I can
confirms the committee that as a matter
of fact this is not correct the relevant
design standard in this case is the
design manual for roads and bridges
another copy here should you wish to
really I'm sure you don't
this principally relates to trunk roads
and motorways a roads and so on it's
therefore a very exacting set of
standards and is somewhat
over-engineering for a be flush rose
just Camden Road nevertheless paragraph
7.30 seconds please sure the relevant
paragraph of the guidance notes that the
width of ghost ions shall not be less
than 2.5 meters therefore flows by
default this is 2.5 meters it's
therefore acceptable I need to standard
so in summary share there been no
haulage objections to the reserved maths
application the junction itself is not
the material playing consideration in
this case it has been constructed
standard and it should not and cannot
therefore hold up the determination this
application thank you Jeff
thank you very much miss Millington
right just for reference and for members
the committee as well we are only
looking at the redline application
before us this evening the the roads
issue has been raised I am fully aware
of the concerns of residents and
parish and district members here this
particular item will be taken out and is
active part of other meetings outside of
this meeting this committee now on this
particular point because obviously there
are concerns I've asked to be kept
informed by highways of the progress of
the meetings etc so picking up your
points that the the highway the roads
issue see how these issues are not
pertinent to this application this
evening and therefore we will not be
considering those as part and parcel of
this application do you want to say
anything on that particular point across
no okay I think that's such everyone
happy with that or clear on that but
thank you mr. Deane's Minton and
concussion are you just highways or is
it that's all you're representing some
oddments for is it in date yet your
stylist yeah
that guard can ask you some other
embarrassing questions in thank you very
much indeed and Andy okay thank you
White Castle bones Thank You mr. German
as you know my concern is the road and
you've just made a statement chairman of
the parish council of Long Marston is
here he also was concerned we wrote to
councilor brain on the 24th of March
still have no reply
although he did to email me yesterday
asked me which policeman I've seen and
which opposite was that I was there with
so he's got an open mind he said we've
had a number of negotiations with the
planning officer over this application a
number of windows we didn't like a
number of bare walls we didn't like the
parish council I think that were
concerned about the entrance but all
those have been I think it rests up to
that point the point really is that in
the outline application the plans for
this junction were put forward they have
not been implemented
if you can move this forward as you can
see on the update sheet unknown to me
there's been a number of people writing
concerned about this thing and on
Tuesday market day there was nearly a
bad accident now as far the planner was
concerned we tried to measure the
central bit and that is two point four
we think with a stick now I appreciate
we didn't do it very well when it was or
week but it wasn't two point five
situation is that it's two meters less
the whole thing is then it should be or
should have been with a cycle way on the
outside the police did have all I didn't
have a word with the police they were
concerned that people over the white
line were careless or whatever the word
was against the against the Highway Code
and also with the cycleway right next to
the road first thing people are going to
do when they can't get by school bus
goes from parks there in the morning
there's no school at the moment nothing
can get by either side so reteach an
urgent thing we were happy with the
planners but we do need to move this
forward the parents counselor here the
chairman is supporting me and the people
and I hadn't realized but there's a
number of other parishes there Clifford
Parish Council of Britain to you and
this isn't in the planning application
but it has got known so we would like
you to either have a meeting we can't
speak to highways they don't speak to us
at the garden center down the road you
know but with an application here was
with both County committee with my
support for a third lane Ireland in 2008
when I got that the road down from 60 to
50 the garden centre wanted a third lane
they were sold they couldn't have one
because it was speed the tropical now
highways won't one so that will will be
going to appeal now there is a problem
Mike will tell you is a problem on that
road he calls the bloody danger
throat but I'm glad to hear that you're
maybe going to move it forward to you
and I must only complement the people
that build the houses for their
cooperation and work that has done and I
think it'll be a it'll be a wonderful
sight Thank You castle and just to
confirm is my understanding is that they
have been full and frank discussions
with the developers and the parish
council and and that you've actually
come to a very reasonable agreement is
that correct the inflammation of the
admin Commission has not been done as
the application should have been and
that's part of the highways well I'm not
particular point he's part of the
outline permission as I mentioned I've
been asked I've asked to be kept
informed on the progress of these
particular items because although it's
not part of the planning application
before us this evening I appreciate that
it's his concerns of the residents so
I've asked to be kept informed on the
progress that one remembers any other
questions of council bars council but
Lorna Thank You chair councillor it am I
right in thinking that you're having
measured this road you don't think it's
been constructed to 2.5 meters which is
the absolute minimum
and I'm going out to stop you there yes
again yeah it's not pertinent to the
application before us this evening but I
appreciate the concerns of everybody any
other questions
no thank you Berta Carson right I'll
open it up for technical questions now
are there any technical questions you'd
like to ask Thank You chair well
reluctantly clarification here that I'm
looking at the report and Warwickshire
highways have got no objection to this
the road has been constructed at a width
which is you know with is legal and
correct is that right I mean you've had
the meetings with highways and I haven't
as chairman said the highway issues is
separate to this application but it's
become wrapped up with a highway
response so the highways were responding
partly about the Station Road Camden
Road junction they've measured it at 2.5
meters wide as the case officer which as
the highway consultant said is the
minimum requirement but Atmos repeat
it's a side issue really we're
considering scale appearance layout and
landscaping yeah that's fine sorry I
didn't want to get sidetracked with it
but it would how much weight you put on
it chairman isn't it technical questions
Thank You chair I'm just looking in the
housing mix sectional report that says
there's a mind disparity against a
preferred mix and that it kind of
vaguely indicates that in the next phase
the the one bed units might be
accommodated through bungalows how
definite are we that the recommended
housing mix of our district will be met
we can't be definite at this stage as
the report says it's slightly out in
comparison to the the core strategy
policy but that is a guide rather than a
definitive statement here
and as you can see from the size of the
site there's a number of phases still to
come through I anticipate that the case
officer will take account of the
cumulative number of different size
houses that are coming forward and keep
a running total and by the time we get
to the end phase we make sure that it
all tallies up and we've got the right
Reich on a mix actually on that
particular point it is obviously very
relevant to interesting question council
that regards the affordable
accommodation I'm assuming that it's
pepper potted and its 10-year blind is
that correct and if these this been
agreed with the parish council as well
please I've got a slide of the
affordable housing layout which I'll
just find I don't know what discussions
have taken place with the parish council
but there is just check which one it is
has it mix plan here we go
so the hazard Oh red are the private
market houses the purple ones are the
affordable rent properties and the
orange ones are the affordable shared
ownership ones as you can see they are
spread throughout the site and that they
in terms of elevations and materials
they will you won't spot any difference
from the the market houses there'll be
the same quality and same material
quality thank you
one concern I do have about the approach
of waiting till the end to see that we
have got all the mix that we are looking
for if developers put forward the ones
that they particularly want before the
ones they don't necessarily want to
build we may end up we want a sort of
the part of this estate for all for
example two beds or one beds I'm just a
little bit concerned about that when I
don't know if then we have a policy on
that how we actually monitor the
aggressive these housing and jump in to
make sure that we do get the right
housing mix was difficult one to have
foresight but what I can say is that
this parcel before members is there are
there abouts through the housing mix as
and when the other parcels come forward
but the officers will have to keep a
running total to make sure nothing gets
too skewed one way or the other it'll be
down to the offices and trusting them to
do that thank you any other questions I
shall open up for debate calibrate and I
just want to clear up cancer bonds in
his presentation suggest I was here with
a not an open mind I am here with an
open mind on the reserved matters the
junction is another matter which is not
before us tonight
he makes certain suggestions which it's
not worth me commenting on but I am here
with an open mind and I fully appreciate
that thank you any other questions I
think I just like the same as a matter
for the record really is how I
appreciate the developers and the parish
talking together on these schemes this
is how it should happen we should be
talking and discussing the the layouts
and make sure that the Paris of the
towns of community getting exactly what
they want from the developers and to be
honest with you the amount of effort
involved for the developers is
relatively relatively small I'm sure as
developer out there will say it's not
but as far as I'm concerned I think the
effort needed at the front end is so
important and it could eliminate a lot
of the debate and discussion and the
arguments and especially appeals that
later on sir well done to the DeLong
Mastan on that particular point or in
debate so I mean I just like to echo
your comments chairman about parish
councils needing to get involved and an
understanding that they have got powers
and persuasive powers they can certainly
persuade members of this committee so
it's good to see looking at this
particular development um
I'm reasonably pleased to actually see
where the afford or
has been located rather than sort of
stuck in one corner you know it seems to
me nicely balanced and even to the north
of the site those houses there or
occupying what would normally be a
fairly prime private residential
position so so well done for agreeing
that again I like the mix of stars I
like that the idea that the prominent
buildings are rendered I like that the
change in building heights and whatever
it's not quite so uniform as a lot of
these estates can be I'm still not 100%
convinced that it is as good as it could
be but I love it's possibly down to my
own perception of aesthetics and how
buildings should look but in this case
I'm very happy to go with as long as as
a recommendation if I can find support
for a second
I'd like to propose that we accept this
application yes I agree with what both
you and a kettle autumn have said and
I'd like the second is well that case
members if there was no other debate I
do have a proposal and I do have a
seconder the item before us is to grant
planning permission for application 17
double-oh-seven 70 to stifle Graham all
those in favor thank you very much
indeed is committee therefore resolved
to grant a planning permission for out
the item 17 double-oh-seven 72 room
thank you very much indeed everybody all
right we're now moving on to our next
item
Tony will vacate the seat
our next item on the agenda this evening
is 17 double-oh-seven 0 2 / 4 3 or 2
close välfärd on Aven and the presenting
officer is Richard
and Thank You Jen the proposal in
question is for the replacement of
existing hanging cladding to the front
and side elevation of the property which
three or she closed with cedar wood
cladding members will see that the
application site is within a residential
cold sack and towards the south of the
village of Welford and even this
existing front end elevation plan shows
in red the section of hanging tiles to
be replaced with cedar wood cladding
this proposed plan likewise shows the
the area to be replaced Reseda wood
cladding and for completeness members
might be interested to know that a
single-story side extension was approved
back in 2016 to be constructed of
materials that match the existing
brickwork and plain tiles of the of the
building and the final photographs I
will show you are the surrounding
properties within the immediate
cul-de-sac which also includes the
application site and members will note
that generally the the character and
appearance of the dwellings is is fairly
uniform with hanging tiles and and red
brickwork common features and in the
opinion of the local planning authority
the introduction of cedar wood cladding
is generally seen as detrimental to the
character and appearance the immediate
vicinity of the site thank you and just
you're aware the the application
therefore is recommended for refusal in
accordance with the reasons sets out in
page 16 of your agenda
thank you very much with you our first
speakers evening is council james
Kimpton
council II have three minutes in your
own time
evening chair the application was
discussed at the parish council meeting
on the 6th of June 2017 the council
heard comments from both the applicant
and one resident of Orchard close who
objected to the application the council
voted to support this application for
the following reasons
any visual harm to the property was
deemed to be a matter of personal taste
and therefore not a relevant planning
reason for a refusal any harm to the
street scene is limited due to the
location orientation and surrounding
vegetation of the property within the
close the introduction of the timber
cladding feature was debated and it was
felt that a precedent had been set or
the introduction of render and cladding
to other properties in similar streets
in the village and the impact would only
be limited due to the previously
mentioned position of the property
Wellford is known more for its variety
and consistency of building form which
complements the picturesque character
the parish council is encourage variety
in style for recent housing developments
helping to prevent houses from looking
alike and I just like to pick up on your
previous comments from the previous
application that it's nice to have
everything that isn't the same and to
have some sort of differential I say
thank you thank you very much
thank you chair a councillor just a
quick but I've not been to orchard place
but but from the presentation am i right
in thinking that this is the only house
in that cul-de-sac with this planning
this cyclist Eiling the rest ought to be
fairly traditional all the houses close
have the tiling they all do this
particular house because of the
vegetation if there was to have timber
cladding you wouldn't be able to see it
thank you any other questions Thank You
cancer
our next speaker is because our Paul
Cooper and Christine Cooper and Juliet
crease and mr. BIG's so right it's
obvious you can sit on the other if you
wish to as you're all registered to
speak and more than welcome to sit up
the at the microphone that is correct
no problem if you press a button at the
bottom that's it I'm a resident of
Orchard close having moved there in 1985
Orchard close is a development of nine
large family home built circa 1972 and
laid out in an open-plan format with
minimal screening and hedges thus
affording views for all residents across
the close towards adjoining properties
the only properties with screening
hedges are numbers one and nine whose
western borders Ajay's are adjacent to
the busy Long Marston Road a major
design feature of the properties is the
hung tile facades which were a major
selling point when the properties were
first built and have been seen as such
by the great majority of residents over
the past forty five years there is a
pleasing variation that designs of the
properties and some have had minor
changes but all have retained their home
tile facades some important background
to the values placed in the past by
Stratford district council planners and
Welford parish council on the street
scene are as follows
the first point plot one remained
undeveloped up to circa 2000 when
planning permission was granted for the
erection of a four-bedroom house with
the stipulation that from both Stratford
District Council and Welford that it
must have home tile facades to maintain
the existing street scene outlook second
point I attended a well fat parish
council meeting circa 2007 when the then
owner of number three had informal
discussions concerning some building
proposals which would include removing
the home tile facade the owner was
informed that Welford parish cancelled
objector their removal and his proposal
did not proceed 0.3 as recently as April
2016 a planning application was
submitted by the current owner of number
three which included the extension
you've seen unless this included the
removal of the hometown facade I'd like
to quote to you from the Welford parish
councils response to this application
nature of submission from Welford to
Stratford was objection the parish
council is happy to support the
extension
of this application but objects to the
proposed change in facade in making this
decision the council was noted that all
properties in orchard closed have the
same tile facade and they're fulfilled
that it would be harmful to the
character and appearance of the closed
if one property were altered as proposed
and this was just every year ago the key
element in well hoods response of just
every year ago concerned objecting to
the removal of the tile facade not what
might go up in its place the objection
was to do with the removal of this tile
facade now nothing has changed in the
appearance of orchard closed in the
intervening 12 months or so and it is
therefore with some surprise that
orchard closed residents find that
Welford Parish Council has completely
reversed its long term positions on the
importance of the total orchard closed
Street seen few residents were aware of
this latest application at the time of
the parish council meeting because as
unlike previous applications when all
residents were contacted only the
residents of adjacent properties were
contacted at this time
number three orchard closed is an
integral part of the overall development
it is not tucked away in a corner has
suggested and is in the direct sight
line of three other orchard closed
properties comparisons with other
developments in Welford are spurious as
there is no other development that has
such a strong architectural feature as
you can continually see which is valued
by the great majority of residents and I
would therefore ask you to reject this
application hello my name is Juliette
crease and I moved to seven orchard
close opposite number three thirty years
ago with my parents when they purchased
the house in 1987 orchard closed was
regarded as an attractive development
with a distinctive theme of home tile
facades which give it a pleasing and
cohesive paragraphs
although there are a small number of
different house designs which have been
adopted and extended over the last 45
years
none have been altered in such a way as
to change the appearance of the street
scene they all still retain the same
Hong tile facades and maintaining the
attractive and cohesive appearance of
the development when a new house is
added to the development in 2000 it was
a requirement that it should feature the
same tile cladding as the rest of the
houses the development is sufficiently
small that only change including to an
individual house would make a
significant detrimental change to the
appearance of the clothes having
maintained the same position for 17
years in objecting to a change in facade
of any of the houses in their
development are being rather surprised
and shocked that welfare parish council
may support the significant alteration
to one of the houses I would also like
to add that unlike previous applications
this time only residency this item
number three were informed where
indirect site and number three and we
didn't have receive any notification at
all the majority there are closes
residents were therefore unaware at the
time of the well for parish councils
meeting are therefore request that you
reject this application my name is
Kristine coop before you start you have
one minutes okay my name is Kristine
Cooper and I live at six orchard close
which directly faces and looks out
towards number three orchard close is
one of the few developments that has
such a strong architectural feature in
the home tile facades and often attracts
positive comment from visitors I highly
value this feature and request that you
reject this application my name is
Roderick Briggs
I have lived at number three orchard
closed since the houses were first built
I highly value the home tile feature
that the houses and the cohesive design
of the whole of orchard closed and
strongly object to this application
thank you rights members are any
questions you'd like to ask okay I just
wanna sleep on the hunk tile stroked the
cedar cladding
which is the main crux of this the whole
the the close it's out there are no
other they're all hunger tiles is that
correct tiles and that has been
maintained so they do actually conform
to planning guidelines current planning
guidelines which I think the planning
officer who confirmed that this
application does not I think it's noted
on your notes committee members that
this does not conform to guidelines
perhaps the Planning Office opinion will
ask question at the appropriate time for
technical passionate but we can ask that
particular question all right any other
questions cordon thank you chairman is
really a question to all of you I mean
obviously the point you're making is
you've got a a unique cul-de-sac here
everything looks the same
I'm getting the impression it's not the
actual materials that are proposed it's
just the fact that you want to retain
every unit in the in the in the slate to
be the same I think the overlying
feature which we try to emphasize is the
hung tiles to replace some tiles with
another material would be contrary and
this property is definitely on view it
isn't okay I think not my question was
going to be thank you for that was was
you know if the house you know on the
main road or something of a similar
thing but but not in here you know a
local resident wanted to change the
cladding or whatever I presume you
wouldn't have any objection on its just
specific to this is built as a total
entity and and has maintained that and
we valued in that 45 years thank you
okay thank you any other questions thank
you very much thank you
our next speaker is Maria Smith and
Martin Lake oh sorry just Martin is it
okay that Martin Lake okay you have have
three minutes for stop the reason we is
not here is their dad died this morning
so unfortunately so she's very
passionate about this so I hope
hopefully I do it justice because she's
done over the work on the whole thing so
I'm very sad I think she's watching so
I'm sorry if I get it wrong so if you
can better so the first the first slide
on there we will show that actually it
is tucked away around the corner you
have to go all the way around the corner
around the side to actually get to see
house in fact many people don't even
know it's there
there have been numerous other planning
permissions granted in Welford there are
a couple of other closes that started
off of seventies houses and they're not
all identical anymore so things are
allowed to change I know your comment
counsel Norton and the the reason that
you like one the other ones is that
they've got some variety in there it's
so it's so whilst II we're not a listed
building so it's not architectural II
significant they're cheap concrete tiles
that were put on the seventies because
the bricks didn't match because there
was a shortage and it's not in the
conservation area so if you you can look
down there the houses are not all
identical there's various variations the
fact that they don't have front fences
and everything is something that we
wouldn't want to change and I do like
that so it's not a uniform Street scene
if you go to the next one as well you
know the houses do look slightly
different if you go to the next one
there all summer side on some affront on
so they have different associations to
the road and if you go to the next one
there's lots of hedges and trees and
things that actually block out part of
the roads the next one is worth it for
me there's no architectural memory I
think there's two factors that have been
put on display here one is that it would
make the house look worse than it
currently does my opinion is this is a
very dated house when I bought it and
always wanted to make it more modern
there are also insulation properties of
cedar that the hung tiles don't have so
we can improve that at the same time so
it's not architect on terms so if you go
to the next one neighbor they basically
there's a lot of extensions there's a
lot of work done
there's a whole thing the photograph
that was taken by the planning office of
that one there you have to stand
physically on our drive to take the
property just to the left of that is a
double garage that we extend that we put
in when we converted the garage at the
front which actually blocks the view
from number two anyway so the only two
people who actually have direct view and
right next door to actually supported it
so the one was right next door
supported it and the ones to the left
which have access from the highest ring
in terms of where we are on that so if
you go if you that's that's the view
from the street until as you go around
the corner and you actually have to get
right in front of our house to actually
actually see the cladding so yes you can
see it from the upstairs of the houses
opposite and I accept that but it's
actually quite a long way away in terms
of that so in terms of all that for me
there's two things there's is it
detrimental to the streets thing well
it's actually not really a street scene
it's a small close and we are tucked
away and the second thing is in my
opinion the hanging tiles are very dated
and actually bringing it more modern and
putting insulation please I do know that
the the we talked about there in the
planning officer talked about adopted
policy cs9 and the aged due to
neighbourhood plan well the neighbour
plan is actually to do with new housing
this isn't new housing this is just
changing the look of an existing house
so I can't see how there's been any
demonstrable harm to the property by the
change or indeed the street scene thank
you that's fine thank you very much
right question I would say do you agree
that within the clothes that albeit
houses there are many different designs
of housing there but they all have the
same tiles around so eight of them have
the original 1972 concrete chief
conquering tiles the number one that was
Bill will have a nut dated version so
isn't the same but they are hanging
tiles on it as well yes okay thank you
and the other reasons for doing this you
mentioned about integration but any
other aesthetic reasons for example for
me as aesthetically
if you look at some of the modern
buildings that are built these days and
I work in building distribution and we
would sell
for me cedar cladding is a beautiful
natural material the actual front of the
house is actually really cold upstairs
because when the tiles were put on you
can't have any blown insulation put in
and they didn't put insulation in so
when we had we moved in we put cavity
insulation in but they won't put it
upstairs so the upstairs gets really hot
or really cold so it gives you the
opportunity to sort that out for me it's
it's a personal thing about
aesthetically it just looks far nicer
and there are many examples in Welford
itself and in Stratford district where
people have changed facades even with
houses otherwise every single clothes
would look the same forever which it
clearly doesn't any other questions
members thank you very much neat
thank you alright our next speaker is
councillor Barnes
as you can see on the agenda I put no
comment which is unusual for me
I went to the parish council meeting the
one side spoke the lady spoke
unfortunately isn't able to come today
and the first camel council were
unanimous in their support maybe a new
parish council but there is changing but
that was a situation as far as I can see
these houses that were built in 85 or
whenever wouldn't be allowed today it's
an urban sprawl in the village and the
village has got different sorts of
properties whichever way you decide to
vote on I'm happy I'm in the middle
thank you rich answer any other
questions for castle those I can't
answer questions though sure you can't
cancel thank you no no questions saw or
so about up thank you very much okay
technical questions I think there was
one yes cancer and by all means if it's
the third I can read extracts from the
specific policy cs9 design instinctive
miss which explains the kind of basis
upon which the planning officer formed
such a decision essentially the policy
says that all forms of development will
improve the quality of the public realm
and enhance the sense of place
reflecting the character and
distinctiveness of the locality
proposals that were damaged will destroy
features which positively contribute to
local distinctiveness will not be
permitted understanding local context is
key to achieving good design and
proposal should take into account where
relevant design principles and
contextual analysis sets out in local
guidance there's n a number of bullet
points and criteria but effectively and
there's a little bit of planning jog and
involved but it says that proposal
should be attractive and be of high
quality architectural design it should
be proposal should be sensitive to the
setting existing built form neighboring
uses landscape character and topography
of the site and locality there is
another criteria in there which does
promote proposals that respond to
climate change
so measures should include energy
efficiency technologies low-carbon and
renewable energy sources and finally
towards the end of the policy in terms
of design innovation
it states that high-quality design
innovation will be encouraged where it
reflects and complements the immediate
local environment and maximizes
sustainable sustainability benefits
where such an approach is appropriate it
should be based on the characteristic to
the building for environment and the
local area and have a beneficial purpose
thank you yeah okay I get your point
here but it it looks at this the whole
thing is about the locals wanted to keep
everything the same but but again
looking at this um they've been a lot of
alterations to these houses over the
years and they've all got double glazed
windows which I suspect weren't there
when we started and they all have a
different design there's no homologous
thing here and again just looking at the
area looking at the treatment of the
overground
you know some some I presume these were
original tarmac drive some are now
blocked pave some different I mean those
would appear to go against policy cs9
and I told you - I just want you to
comment on that please acknowledge that
there is an element of subjectivity
involved in obviously appraising design
and an appropriateness of materials
obviously it was the planning judgement
wearing at the various in interest it
was decided that given the uniformed
character and appearance of the
dwellings in question with the the
common materials found amongst them all
in the clothes that the preservation of
attention of those was was given
arguably more weight than design
innovation
but it is readily accepted there is an
element of subjectivity in that which is
being asked of you tonight
any other questions open up the debate
casts bring chairman I know this
development quite well I would say it's
unique in Welford there are different
designs in wealth over this estate or
clothes is unique and I have to say the
tiles are a unique feature of the
overall standard of the housing so I
think it would be detrimental to the
street scene it's against policy and
emphasize it's an important design
feature of the whole clothes so I will
be supporting officers recommendation
thank you I think I'll just it is an
interesting one this because on the one
hand to just make some changes to the
facade of dwelling you think more that's
not a big deal but put into the context
of the close I think one of the speakers
said it like a total entity and in that
particular context I have to agree
because albeit I appreciate that the
London Life moved on and materials have
moved on and energy efficiencies moved
on from from these things but in end of
the day that is still a major design
feature this particular area I don't
agree with the comment made about the
there are other dwellings around that
have got this cladding that's not really
relevant to this particular right
discussion as far as I'm concerned it is
all about this close
so I too am I'm supportive of the
officers view in this particular case
from looking at the various Sun pictures
the street scene it would appear that
the only thing that they have in common
is the the cladding because the
different styles as accounts a lot and
picked up different windows there's been
many extensions and it's not in a
conservation area and whilst you know a
lot of the recommendations are in
keeping with cs9 we mustn't forget the
environmentally sustainable changes I'll
be making
and with a position of the house you
actually would have to be in an upstairs
bedroom of enables to actually see the
change it's not going to generally
affect their the street scene from what
the applicant said so I won't be
supporting their refusal definitely any
hard pushed it's just the only thing
they've got in common is the tiles but
they're so varied in design the house is
now canceled Thank You chair yeah that
this is this is very very finely
balanced in my view I could fully
understand the objections from the
neighbors and you know I can fully
understand the very sound reasons that
the applicant wants here certainly in
respect of modernizing the property and
probably more importantly providing some
adequate insulation because this type of
housing at this type of hanging tile is
something of its time and it certainly
wouldn't be allowed now under current
building regulations I'm very much in
the middle of this I'm going to take
weight from the support from the parish
council however and obviously there has
been support from other people in the in
the in the in the cul-de-sac
so my view slightly is on this occasion
to go against the officers
recommendation and grant this
application and I'd be happy to make a
proposal in that respect if I could find
a second
I'm happy to do that do I have a second
on that one thank you
the vote before us members is okay well
I have a slight problem I don't think we
did hear a proposal specifically could
you confirm what you said I said I
supported the officers recommendation if
you want me to move the recommendation
on page 15 and 16 okay I have to say
that it's not a formal so the the the
council Wharton's proposal first has to
be heard first council Lorton you have
made a proposal to refuse that's also to
go
the officers recommendation and granting
permission do you have a seconder
councillor O'Donnell the vote before you
is to grant it planning permission for
item 17 sash double-oh-seven no to such
fault all those in favor all those in
favor against thank yes lost
okay the - I have a proposal now for the
to refuse plan permission proposed
recommendation on page 50
thank you don't have a second that
counselor pain thank you the boat before
is there for is to refuse planning
permission for 1707 0 for 2 for all
those in favor against so again this
committee therefore resolves to refuse
plan for mission for 75 double-oh-seven
0 to start all thank you the final item
on the agenda this evening is 17
double-o 696 lat
slash very this is long orchard barn
bintang and it's Richard is the
presenting officer again
thank you sure as mentioned the
application now before members is for
the proposed removal of a agricultural
occupancy condition tied to an
agricultural workers dwelling improved
in nineteen eighty at long orchard farm
Welford a Navin the initial slides
illustrate the location of the site in
relation to the rider village the
application site is to the north of the
village just outside the built-up area
boundary of the settlement as defined in
the emerging Welford uneven neighborhood
development plan the understanding of
the local authority is there
historically the most recent
agricultural use of the site has been a
pig breeding and fattening enterprise as
well as market gardening that seemingly
took place predominantly between 1979
and 2000 when this use ceased the
application seeks to divorce the
existing dwelling from the agricultural
use of the land to create an open market
dwelling the following slides are now
run through show the range of
agricultural buildings and pig sheds
presence of the application site as well
as the agricultural workers dwelling
itself it is understood that
agricultural activity on the site ceased
at least 10 years ago there is no
evidence available to dispute this
assertion the dwelling has lain vacant
for the last year according to the
applicant the application has been
accompanied by a viability assessment
and to summarize its findings it
contests that the occupancy condition
has outlived its usefulness and there is
no longer a continued need for an
agricultural worker to be based on site
the commercial viability of the site for
agricultural use is considered limited
and any financial costs involved in
recommencing agricultural activity of
the site an economic or prohibitive the
findings of the viability assessment are
generally accepted however no marketing
has taken place to test the level of
interest locally or
the site for agricultural use therefore
it is considered the insufficient
information has been provided to warrant
refusal of the occupancy sorry therefore
it is considered the insufficient
justification has been provided to war a
refusal of the occupancy condition
separating the dwelling from the
agricultural use of the land
therefore chairman the recommendation is
to refuse the application for the
reasons set out in the reports which can
be viewed on page 27 of your agendas
thank you our first speaker is the
councillor Kimpton again I think you
know the way now don't you good evening
again the parish council considered this
application its committee meeting on the
25th of March 2017 and voted to refuse
it is clear that planning permission was
only granted for a dwelling in this
location on the basis that it was
required for use associated with
agriculture it is not in an area where
development would normally be permitted
it out as it is outside the built-up
boundary of Welford our position is
consistent with current planning policy
under policy a s-10 of the core strategy
which restricts development in the open
countryside the site and its
outbuildings are also in the floodplain
and he9 of the Welford on Aven
Neighborhood Development Plan states
that development within these flood
zones will be opposed unless it does not
result in any additional properties
being placed at risk of flooding no
evidence was supplied by the applicant
stating that this would be the case the
parish counts will support local
employment which is the case with
agricultural consents thank you thank
you canceling right the existing site
have you any knowledge of the Council of
the use of that particular site and the
fact that it's now not a viable site are
you aware of not being a farmer or an
agricultural specialist I couldn't say
whether it's viable or not one would say
you could possibly make it viable
you could also make sure that it wasn't
viable thank you for observation
any other questions Thank You counsel
our next speaker is Alan Bohr and tomba
doc thank you you have three minutes
between you in your own time
Thank You chair just to correct you I'm
Alan law reading agricultural
consultants I felt limited playing a
permission was granted December 1980 for
a permanent dwelling 37 years ago this
was to support 70 Sal indoor unit on a
farm which only has four and a half
acres these types of small farms were
common during the the 80s and there was
an established need however agriculture
particularly livestock farming has
changed significantly since then with
the number of these smaller dwellings
being very much reduced if you look at
the National Statistics many of these
small units have either been absorbed by
a larger neighboring farmer or converted
to light industrial or gone for housing
development
there's been no agricultural activity on
the farm for at least 10 years and the
house has been vacant for at least one
year the agricultural buildings as you
saw in a dilapidated state and are no
longer fit for purpose the land is in
the floodplain and liable to flooding
the buildings would not meet current
legislation for the welfare of animals
to rebuild the buildings for pigs
poultry glass houses would be provided
prohibitive in my view and unlikely to
be sanctioned by any bank for any such
loans for conversion in addition the
mitigation measures to prevent flooding
would significantly add to any set up
costs the council have accepted and
agreed that the holding is not viable an
IRAC report
the council in agreeing to a change of
use of the buildings on the farm to b 1
and b 8 in 2004 some 13 years ago in my
view have accepted that farming
operations at the site are not viable or
very limited indeed any farming activity
ceased there in 2007 the farm was not
viable no farmer can support a business
where costs and expenditure are
constantly way in excess of any income
it's just suicidal the council have
accepted the farm is not viable but
consider as the farmhouse and land have
not been marketed it cannot support the
application my submission to the
committee is that it has already been
demonstrated that marketing of the
property would serve no useful purpose
and indeed in the case of the Hambleton
district council vs. Secretary of State
and Barca it agreed no marketing of a
similar property to illustrate the
marketing was not necessary to cut the
courts agreed with that and that there
was no realistic realistic assessment of
a continuing need for an occupation
agricultural occupation condition in the
applicants case a market in the exercise
would again serve no useful purpose the
small farm is not viable the costs of
any form of inch infrastructure three
four five seconds to again support an
agricultural enterprise will be
prohibitive the council accept the mark
and exercise is unlikely to find a
purchaser who can meet the AOC in my
view it is a futile acces exercise and I
would urge the council to approve the
application thank you very much - thank
you very much first members only
questions you might ask mr. law all the
questions I have though is this I think
it's accepted that the actual business
as a farm as a relatively small farm
isn't necessarily viable and I think
that's been accepted by the officer he's
saying yes
it's not so much that is it in my
opinion this is all about the dwelling
the the condition on that dwelling
addiction before agriculture use it
doesn't tie it to the farm therefore has
it been marketed within the farm with
the agricultural within the agricultural
community for use by agricultural
workers no it hasn't
chair but I would venture the the view
that this this farm has been has not
been a farm for at least ten years and
in my experience any neighboring farmer
would know that this property was wood
would be available over the last ten
years and knowing farmers they would
have been knocking on the applicants
door making her an offer for that
particular dwelling no such things have
happened and in my experience if if a
neighboring farmer was wanting to bark
wanting to purchase that he would have
already done that and a marketing
exercise to to actually check on that to
my mind is absolutely futile and a waste
of expense okay thank you
oh there any other questions members
thank you very much indeed thank you
but Casavant just for change
well you never know
okay I support the application for a
number of reasons when we did have a pig
farm there we had a lot of problems with
smell as you probably know the four
rules public ash which is now quite a
posh restaurant he's just down the
southwesterly wind environmental health
came out a number of times it was a
continual battle I suppose since the
time the pigs have gone and the man
retired funnily enough when the house
was built it was built on stilts which
was quite a bit of a laugh really cos
nobody realized what flooding was in
1980 90s and it's still on stilts they
an opposite and a distribution center
was formed next door and as I say with
the four walls as it is I don't think
well I know there's any livestock there
who would would be detrimental to the
business the other thing is obviously
that we do don't allow houses you know
open countryside but it's already there
we have to a certain extent come to our
quota nearly in the village but we have
had 38 houses outside the in the parish
but not in the village boundary which is
nearly agreed so as far as I'm concerned
I think there is one letter of support I
don't know who it's from but as you know
the locals that live around there and
the boat station you'll see is on the
left hand side have 200 boats it looks
bigger there but you can see the boat
station now see how closely for all's is
whether the sign is it's on the back
flow of the river in the respect that
the water comes up to the road as far as
called back flow so it doesn't flow to
you badly but we don't want the page
back that that's the simple fact and
since then the businesses
have thrived so I think it will have a
detrimental effect if we have the
livestock back so I'm supporting the
house being we came there with the
condition that there is no live stuff I
would want that because as I know where
I was on the phone constantly on think
Rob weeks was the head of environmental
health there so you can tell how long
ago it was but since the pigs have gone
and the gentleman passed away and it's
sort of been left as it is we haven't
had any problems so as far as I'm
concerned I'm quite happy for this up
this house to stay where it is be an
individual house without an agricultural
toy and that's basically it so I have
got some comment on this there's that
and I'm quite happy to answer any
questions I think it will be a local
benefit instead of being what really was
at one time we do want businesses in
villages but this is inappropriate in
the wrong place thank you culture
basically the same question the business
the the fig farming business isn't
relevant to this particular application
because this is all about the actual
dwelling and it's tied to agricultural
use ie people working within
agricultural environment is that what
you're understanding right as well there
because there was livestock there was a
bit extra land that isn't used by the
piece but that was grazed and they did
sort of try and do a bit of
horticultural work on it but rejected
because the actual condition the
original condition stated for
agricultural use it didn't say
specifically for that particular farm no
oh oh I see what I see where you're
coming from
yes well I do know a number of farmers
that did think of looking at it but
they didn't really want to know because
under IEC rules you have to be close to
where you work or livestock that's the
problem with you okay thank you any
other questions thank you very cancer
all right open it for technical
questions um first one would you can you
just go over please you didn't mention
it about the the fact that you don't
believe the advertised it now I know
that mr. Blore said it was a futile very
futile exercise but in your opinion did
they do due diligence in that respect by
advertising it and hence thank you chair
in terms of background the application
originally came in simply for the
proposal
there was no viability or marketing
information accompanying the submission
myself as the case officer simply
requested in the planning agency a
fication as to ever any viability or
marketing had been done and we were told
but no more formal marketing had
completely taken place following that in
the subsequent days mr. Badal I believe
was engaged to provide a viability
assessment my professional competency as
you'd expect isn't really stretched to
the economic understanding of whether
it's viable or not but he's a
professionally accredited you know
individual with the expertise in such
matters so we take his advice at face
value and we have no reason to dispute
that in all likelihood the site probably
isn't viable
for its present use as you say the
agricultural tie itself
or the tie itself and relates to a
condition from 1980 that simply states
that the dwellings should be used for
agricultural forestry purposes by the
individual or their dependents as you
say there is not really any specific tie
to the use of the piggery so my
understanding is based on email
exchanges and conversation to the
planning agent and all normal marketing
it's taking place but you are correct to
say that although that hasn't
in place we do accept the find into the
viability reports that it probably would
be prohibitive or likely generate little
interest in the use in its current
agricultural form okay thank you
Thank You chair I'll ask you a planning
question if from this building is
retained and the and the land is
properly marketed and somebody came
along for example wanting to use it as a
Market Garden smallholding that sort of
thing the applicants agent said that in
the current conditions you couldn't
glasshouses up but I'm just wondering
could you put up poly tunnels or
something less permanent would it would
be a planning issue in turning this into
a market garden does that come under
agricultural what we'd be looking at
then was the extent of the proposals in
terms of whether it's Politan all glass
houses there are certain levels of
permitted development for agricultural
buildings and structures I don't know
them at the moment off the top of my
head so we would then establish whether
it needed planning permission I suspect
because we're in a flood zone
it would require permission and then
those structures would then be judged as
to whether they were harmful to the open
countryside location or whether that
harm was offset and outweighed by the
continuation of the use of the land in
agriculture use I think that's that's a
perhaps yes then effectively the
condition would create you know it's
just an open market dwelling be wider
kind of agricultural site setting would
would in all likelihood on balance
probably remain as that and so but my
colleague Andy's correct at the certain
admitted development rights might mean
and they can do do do things like
there'd like Polly tunnels without
needing formal planning permission so
Sharon if I may so my understanding if
this was marketed somebody came along
and
to open it as a Market Garden Center
something like that
not a piggery what I've heard not the
buildings down whatever they could still
live in that house as an agricultural
worker yes undoubtedly because those
uses that you've referred to or within
agricultural use casts brain
almost forgot what I wanted to say I
understand that some reservations about
you being influenced on two and three
and I assume that's why it's built on
stilts in the first place I'm assuming
that there was an application for a new
house there it wouldn't hold water
you are in every plan an application is
to expect be treated on its own
individual merits but as it's being
mentioned previously the site is located
outside the bill to define built-up area
boundary of the emerging well for the
Navin Neighborhood Development Plan so
effectively it's considered in policy
terms an open countryside location
obviously depending on the scale of
development in residential development
the the nature and specific design
incorporated into I can't say that you
know residential developments that site
would be rejected but there would
probably be some resistance for him from
the local planning authority because of
its location and sustainability in
relation to the general planning
material considerations thank you any
other questions yes sir you mentioned a
neighborhood plan it's a stage that kind
of significant way to understand daddies
correct I believe it's had its
referendum so whilst the course the
doctor core strategy currently takes
predominance along with the national
planning policy framework and as time
goes by and in the future were expecting
a neighborhood plan to be formally
adopted it does carry significant weight
at the moment it will carry full weight
and should be seared to accord with the
core strategy but yes you are correct
that in terms of flood risk the existing
dwelling is on stilts as councillor
balances explained but the site
generally I think is accepted to be in
flood zone and two and three so we would
expect flood risk assessment to be made
sequential test an exception tests were
an application forthcoming and for
residential development to show how and
there would be no adverse flood risk
I've on this
or to neighboring land uses okay thank
you
right any other technical questions no
I'm sure open up for debate
councillors Thank You chairman I think
where I am on this is that I'm not
satisfied that this particular small
holding has been adequately marketed I'm
not happy to release what is a very
binding condition on this property it
wouldn't exist if it wasn't due to this
agricultural try it certainly wouldn't
exist if it was going to be built now I
think the only way that I could be happy
about this in any way would be if I've
got clear evidence of a very detailed
lengthy marketing campaign for a local
reputable agent and hopefully at a price
that will sell or rent that will lease
so I'm gonna support and will propose
that we go with the officers
recommendations and refuse this
but second is proposal I think before we
just go to the vote on this particular
point it is relevant that we don't want
to lose agricultural properties of one
form or another in fairness the actual
proposal is not for the to market for
example the viability of the site I
think obviously as a farm that's been
accepted by the local planning authority
that it's not it is for the house and it
will be retained with him and the
agricultural community shall we say so
again I'm struggling I don't think it's
been marketed enough we've had a number
of applications recently where we've
actually gone back to them until the
12th us and said prove it and when they
have proven it then we have made our
decision and sometimes it's come with
the developers I don't believe it's been
due diligence of him showing in this
particular case so again I I will go
with the officer on this particular
point right any other debate if not I've
got a proposer which is council Orton
and cancer brain or the seconder
gentlemen and ladies lady the vote
before you is the 17th double O six nine
sessions very for refused planning
permission all those in favor
that's unanimous chairman thank you this
committee therefore resolves for refused
plane tuition for seventeen stocked up
low six - Roxbury thank you
that is the last item on the agenda this
evening thank you very much indeed
everybody and good night